hey guys how's it going on whatever day
it is today
alright so if you guys have been
following me on Twitter or my own
website you know that I've been updating
you guys on this new internet censorship
bill it's been called a few things the e
parasite Act SOPA the protect IP Act
whatever it is it is internet censorship
and also if you guys have been following
my updates you know that I am adamantly
against this thing all right so the
government says they want to push this
through Congress because they're trying
to crackdown on internet piracy yeah if
only copywriting wasn't a federal
offense before oh wait look at that it
is so I don't get the point of this new
bill but beyond all the excuses
I think I know why they want to pass it
basically the scariest thing about this
new bill is it says if someone uploads
copyrighted material to a web site it is
a federal crime you are a criminal now
and the website that gets uploaded to is
now taken down which then leads to thank
holy the fall of Facebook Twitter
and YouTube now I know the argument is
and people have said this to me before
is that YouTube isn't responsible for
the content uploaded there's just the
host agreed but that's not what the bill
says the bill says that if copyrighted
material is uploaded onto a web site the
owner and host of that web site is
legally responsible and there is so much
new content that's uploaded onto YouTube
on a daily basis there is no way that
Google will be able to catch everything
it's a very community-based network
people find infringed material they flag
it and YouTube investigates it and they
say oh yeah it is or no it's not but
under the scrutiny of this new bill
which they want to make a law the
government could just be like I know
that's copyrighted material you're out
that website down and that's done it's
the government done the reason it's
worrisome is because I've had a
copyright infringement case put against
me there was a studio that opened one
against me for reasons I have yet to
know now I fought it on YouTube and it
was taken away because you know I wasn't
in the wrong but under this new bill
they could just open the copyright
infringement case against me the
government BAM wipes out my channel and
wipes out YouTube and they can blacklist
my name you Google Jeremy John's can't
find me yeah everything gets wiped out
before you can even prove your case
guilty until proven innocent oh and I'm
being tried as a criminal now tubed
awesome and we think about how many
bootleg versions of The Avengers trailer
did you see online this year yeah a lot
YouTube would be gone and how many like
music videos have you seen where people
cut together trailers with music in the
background yet YouTube's gone that what
that was uploaded on face
book - well that's gone now - Oh someone
uploaded something on Twitter that's
gone - and I think that's the problem
because if you look at the supporters of
this new bill it's all really big
Hollywood Studios Screen Actors Guild
screenwriters guild the opposers are all
online based yeah this tug of war
between people's attention spans you've
always had that I mean you look at it
less people are going to movies why
because people are being entertained
online you can go on YouTube you can
find stand-up comedy entertainment
reviews and if people are watching that
they're not paying $10 a ticket to see a
mediocre movie and I think that's what
this thing is all about
I think this bill was written by a bunch
of old ass bureaucrats who want to go
back to the time before VCRs I say
before VCRs because when the VCR was
coming out big Hollywood studios wanted
to fight that too because they could
record tapes the Internet is community
based and people have a larger voice and
they've ever had before in the history
of mankind
that sounds pretty big for me to say but
honestly if you think about it it's true
you have an opinion on something you can
get it out there the internet gives
people power and as long as people have
power big corporations and politicians
they have less power and they don't like
that I think this bill is nothing better
control ploys the government trying to
maintain control of the people if the
government takes away these networking
sites then we don't have a say in
reality the internet lets people pursue
what America itself is actually based on
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness you can pursue your goals
online you can actually open a business
and operate it online social networking
sites like YouTube and Facebook they are
important and they're integral in
maintaining that you take those away and
it just hurts us the common people big
businesses big studios big corporations
politicians they don't care so they're
gonna use the power that they do have to
blot us out bigger companies that
operate online could just blot out
little companies that are trying to
start up it's like oh I don't like them
boom copyright infringement case they're
gone I don't like them either bam bam
bam they're gone it's just absolutely
tilted against anyone who's gonna try to
start up anything online and it's unfair
and that's the thing here is a reality
check these people these representatives
in Washington they are your
representatives they're supposed to
represent you and us the people which is
not happening because I have not run
into one human being that actually wants
this bill to pass yet they are pushing
for it to pass it's selfish and it only
serves them
online networking sites YouTube the
internet is responsible for a lot of
revenue circulation you want to help the
economy just stay out of the internet
government it makes more money for the
people than the Hollywood studios going
to oh no but in this economy we've got a
silence and wipe out a main revenue
stream for the American people and
people of the world makes no sense and
if you're in another country you're like
I'm not American this doesn't affect me
it's the World Wide Web dude it affects
you it just does it sucks but it does
like I actually said in the letter to my
congressman this bill is like burning
down your house because you have an ant
problem yeah I actually wrote my
Congressman I put least below two
petitions you can sign they're being
sent off to congressmen right now I put
a link below where you can actually
write your Congressman personally if you
want a personal touch on it sign those
things get them out there just blot this
thing out of existence on my website
wwlp.com it-- Witter as to how this
whole fight is going I mean it disturbs
me that this bill was even thought of
let alone has gotten this far to where
the government wants to pass it but if
it passes
yeah help us all as V from V for
Vendetta once said people should not be
afraid of their governments government
should be afraid of their people they
have clearly lost sight of that you know
that because they want to pass a bill
that helps big studios because well big
studios probably helped them get
reelected so go to the links below let
them know that this is and they
have to listen to you because in reality
this little bill is gonna go bad as far
as we let it so let's just not let it